Speaker 1: And I want to talk about a very
Speaker 1: controversial subject today, the subject of
Speaker 1: ego death.
Speaker 1: And we chose the title ego death not
Speaker 1: because I really understand what it is,
Speaker 1: because I don't think very many people do,
Speaker 1: but because it was very provocative.
Speaker 1: So this is a very controversial question
Speaker 1: about enlightenment what happens to the ego,
Speaker 1: and does the ego die or not?
Speaker 1: And if it does, what is?
Speaker 1: What does it really mean?
Speaker 1: So this is something I've been thinking
Speaker 1: about for a good 35 years, so I know a
Speaker 1: little bit about it and I have a lot of
Speaker 1: experience in this area.
Speaker 1: But uh, it's very confusing.
Speaker 1: It remains to be a confusing question
Speaker 1: because so many so-called experts,
Speaker 1: including me, seem to disagree with each
Speaker 1: other about fundamentals.
Speaker 1: So this is a very confusing area.
Speaker 1: It's a very confusing topic.
Speaker 1: Theoretically.
Speaker 1: A lot of people seem to have it figured out,
Speaker 1: but I I really question whether anybody has
Speaker 1: it figured.
Speaker 1: I have a lot of different ideas about it.
Speaker 1: I have a lot of different thoughts which I
Speaker 1: think are important, significant, relevant
Speaker 1: and helpful, and I work with them myself to
Speaker 1: try to make sense, out of my own experience
Speaker 1: of enlightenment, how confusing it is
Speaker 1: sometimes, and I think, if you're willing
Speaker 1: to just consider some of the things I'm
Speaker 1: saying, some of the my own experience of
Speaker 1: enlightenment, how confusing it is
Speaker 1: sometimes.
Speaker 1: And I think if you're willing to just
Speaker 1: consider some of the things I'm saying,
Speaker 1: some of the paradoxes that I will present
Speaker 1: to you, I think it'll help you to come to
Speaker 1: terms with the question that is ultimately
Speaker 1: very mysterious.
Speaker 1: Because the question of what does it mean
Speaker 1: to be what is enlightenment number one?
Speaker 1: to be what is enlightenment number one and
Speaker 1: what does it mean for a human being, which
Speaker 1: is who and what we all are, to actually
Speaker 1: manifest enlightened awareness?
Speaker 1: If enlightenment exists, if it's real, if
Speaker 1: what people like the Buddha and the Ramana
Speaker 1: Maharshi, if what they were speaking about
Speaker 1: is true, what does that miraculous and
Speaker 1: mysterious state of consciousness walk like
Speaker 1: and talk like and act like?
Speaker 1: And what does it have to do with the very
Speaker 1: real day-to-day experience of each and
Speaker 1: every one of us, especially for those of us
Speaker 1: who are doing our best to take
Speaker 1: enlightenment seriously and are taking our
Speaker 1: own potential for enlightenment seriously,
Speaker 1: for those of us who are serious about it,
Speaker 1: which not very many people are, but for
Speaker 1: those of us who are serious about it or at
Speaker 1: least believe we're serious about it.
Speaker 1: We might be deluded, of course also, but
Speaker 1: for those of us who believe we're serious
Speaker 1: about it, what does it mean to be
Speaker 1: enlightened?
Speaker 1: What does it look like, what does it walk
Speaker 1: like, what does it talk like, what does it
Speaker 1: feel like?
Speaker 1: And that's always the question I've been
Speaker 1: interested in, because I was always aware
Speaker 1: that the theory I would read about, the
Speaker 1: theory of what enlightenment looks like,
Speaker 1: acts like, walks like and talks like, and I
Speaker 1: would want to know what does this really
Speaker 1: mean about our humanity?
Speaker 1: How do we express this miraculous state of
Speaker 1: consciousness in and through the complexity
Speaker 1: of our human consciousness?
Speaker 1: And so, especially when I was a younger man
Speaker 1: and I was still a seeker, I went to see as
Speaker 1: many supposedly enlightened teachers,
Speaker 1: masters and gurus as I could, because I
Speaker 1: wanted to know what enlightenment looked
Speaker 1: like, not just what it was like, what it
Speaker 1: was supposed to be like, from a theoretical
Speaker 1: or abstract, intellectual perspective,
Speaker 1: philosophical perspective, but I wanted to
Speaker 1: know what enlightened human beings actually
Speaker 1: look like.
Speaker 1: And it's very confusing, because the whole
Speaker 1: notion of enlightenment emerged in two and
Speaker 1: a half thousand years ago, three thousand
Speaker 1: years ago, during the mythic era, and so
Speaker 1: enlightenment for many people means a state
Speaker 1: of that which is perfect, a state of
Speaker 1: perfection, a state of that which is
Speaker 1: perfect, a state of perfection, a state of
Speaker 1: human perfection.
Speaker 1: And human perfection in the Enlightenment
Speaker 1: context usually means that the separate
Speaker 1: self-sense, the unique, separate self-sense
Speaker 1: has been utterly obliterated.
Speaker 1: And I'm just speaking metaphorically, I'm
Speaker 1: not speaking literally.
Speaker 1: It's what we imagine in the mythic context
Speaker 1: that the separate ego, that the separate
Speaker 1: self-sense has been utterly and radically
Speaker 1: obliterated and what's left is a human
Speaker 1: being whose consciousness is more or less
Speaker 1: fundamentally only aware of the
Speaker 1: consciousness of cosmic unity, of what some
Speaker 1: people call God consciousness in their
Speaker 1: separate eye sense, a unique, separate eye,
Speaker 1: sense of being, a unique ego has been
Speaker 1: utterly destroyed, once and for all and
Speaker 1: forever.
Speaker 1: And so to be in the presence of such a
Speaker 1: being is to be in the presence of one of
Speaker 1: God, really God appearing through the body,
Speaker 1: mind, personality of a unique human being,
Speaker 1: man or woman.
Speaker 1: But it's the God consciousness which is
Speaker 1: fundamentally what's being expressed In the
Speaker 1: separate I sense, the separate ego sense,
Speaker 1: the personal and unique identity is gone
Speaker 1: forever.
Speaker 1: At least this is the mythic idea.
Speaker 1: And as all of us are aware of the story,
Speaker 1: that in the late 60s and 1970s, when many
Speaker 1: hippies in the late 60s and 1970s, when
Speaker 1: many hippies who discovered glimpses of
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness through the taking of
Speaker 1: ingesting psychedelic substances, traveled
Speaker 1: to India and were seeking the company of
Speaker 1: true enlightened masters, and they met many
Speaker 1: of them.
Speaker 1: Many enlightened masters were brought back
Speaker 1: to America and to Europe.
Speaker 1: This is when these mythic beliefs, these
Speaker 1: mythic ideas of the perfect state of
Speaker 1: enlightenment crashed into Western
Speaker 1: psychology and the postmodern scrutiny and
Speaker 1: deep understanding of human nature, and
Speaker 1: then everybody started to see that these
Speaker 1: enlightened masters were also shockingly
Speaker 1: human, not always in the best ways.
Speaker 1: There's so many examples of these kinds of
Speaker 1: stories.
Speaker 1: And then many people said well, if
Speaker 1: enlightened beings are especially stressing
Speaker 1: human imperfection and issues around ego
Speaker 1: and power and narcissism and the usual kind
Speaker 1: of weaknesses, maybe enlightenment doesn't
Speaker 1: mean anything and maybe, after all, it
Speaker 1: doesn't really exist.
Speaker 1: Maybe it's all been a myth, but that's the
Speaker 1: short story of what happened and in spite
Speaker 1: of that many of us kept going and didn't
Speaker 1: give up.
Speaker 1: So that's the overarching context of the
Speaker 1: story.
Speaker 1: So I think most people are interested in
Speaker 1: this topic, begrudgingly will admit that
Speaker 1: enlightenment does exist, but most people
Speaker 1: don't really know what it means.
Speaker 1: And these days a lot of people are very
Speaker 1: cynical, become very cynical about whether
Speaker 1: enlightenment is real or whether it's even
Speaker 1: attainable whether it's even attainable.
Speaker 1: So we're living in a context right now, in
Speaker 1: a cultural context, where I'm speaking in
Speaker 1: broad strokes, I'm making big general
Speaker 1: statements that don't apply to everybody by
Speaker 1: any stretch of the imagination, and more
Speaker 1: people now tend to be interested in
Speaker 1: psychological healing rather than
Speaker 1: enlightenment, and they're not the same
Speaker 1: thing, and I really wanted to emphasize at
Speaker 1: the beginning of this talk that
Speaker 1: psychological healing is not enlightenment,
Speaker 1: and the awakening to enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: which is what enlightenment is all about,
Speaker 1: is not about psychological healing.
Speaker 1: Psychological healing is about the attempt
Speaker 1: to heal our childhood wounds, unresolved
Speaker 1: traumas and things like that, which is what
Speaker 1: everybody seems to be talking about these
Speaker 1: days.
Speaker 1: But the quest for enlightenment is a search
Speaker 1: for the direct experience, the liberating
Speaker 1: experience, the liberating experience,
Speaker 1: experience, the liberating experience, the
Speaker 1: liberating experience, the liberating
Speaker 1: experience of the awakening to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, which is a thing that exists.
Speaker 1: Enlightenment is the awakening.
Speaker 1: Enlightened awareness is a higher state of
Speaker 1: consciousness.
Speaker 1: It's what the buddha was pointing to, it's
Speaker 1: what he was calling all of us to, which ram
Speaker 1: maharishi was speaking about when he called
Speaker 1: awakening to the self.
Speaker 1: It's what my own guru, the great HW Alpunja,
Speaker 1: was speaking about when he talked about
Speaker 1: awakening to the self with a capital S.
Speaker 1: So just to make a simple distinction that
Speaker 1: everybody is already aware of clear,
Speaker 1: enlightenment is about transcending the ego
Speaker 1: and the small self, and psychological work
Speaker 1: is about transcending the ego and the small
Speaker 1: self, and psychological work is about
Speaker 1: healing the ego and the small self.
Speaker 1: I want to make clear that enlightenment is
Speaker 1: about transcendence.
Speaker 1: That's not a new idea.
Speaker 1: It's about transcending the small self
Speaker 1: completely, totally, radically and
Speaker 1: absolutely, at least for a period of time,
Speaker 1: and about experiencing a state of
Speaker 1: consciousness that is utterly unaffected
Speaker 1: and untouched by anything that the ego's
Speaker 1: ever experienced.
Speaker 1: That's why it's so liberating, because it's
Speaker 1: different territory.
Speaker 1: It's territory where there's innocence and
Speaker 1: purity and the presence of eternity and
Speaker 1: unthinkable and unimaginable positivity,
Speaker 1: the experience of which and the knowledge
Speaker 1: of which is utterly transformational.
Speaker 1: It doesn't necessarily heal the ego, but it
Speaker 1: transcends it.
Speaker 1: The ego temporarily disappears, doesn't die
Speaker 1: forever, but in the state of transcendence
Speaker 1: the ego is nowhere to be found and
Speaker 1: psychological healing is about
Speaker 1: psychological healing and it all needs to
Speaker 1: be done.
Speaker 1: We all need to be doing it, we want to be
Speaker 1: happy, but I sometimes think that too many
Speaker 1: people these days are confusing
Speaker 1: psychological work with the work of
Speaker 1: transcendence, and they're not the same
Speaker 1: thing.
Speaker 1: They're both necessary and important, but
Speaker 1: they're not identical, they're not the same
Speaker 1: thing, they're very, very different.
Speaker 1: And some people are just more interested in
Speaker 1: psychological healing, more interested in
Speaker 1: coming to terms with their woundedness and
Speaker 1: their unresolved traumas that are still
Speaker 1: bothering them, and that's absolutely
Speaker 1: reasonable and totally fine.
Speaker 1: And some other people, myself included,
Speaker 1: have always been more interested in
Speaker 1: transcendence than in healing, and I know
Speaker 1: I'm not supposed to say that in polite
Speaker 1: company, but it's just true.
Speaker 1: They're not the same thing.
Speaker 1: And be wary or be careful when
Speaker 1: psychological healing and enlightenment are
Speaker 1: spoken about in the same breath, or when a
Speaker 1: spiritual guru says the same thing, they're
Speaker 1: not.
Speaker 1: Or if a psychotherapist says the same thing,
Speaker 1: they're not.
Speaker 1: I once asked my guru, who had a very big
Speaker 1: ego.
Speaker 1: He had an enormous ego, unbelievable, and
Speaker 1: he also had a very big ego.
Speaker 1: he also had a very big enlightenment.
Speaker 1: His enlightenment was unimaginably huge,
Speaker 1: enormous, vast, incomprehensible,
Speaker 1: mysterious, overwhelming ecstasy producing.
Speaker 1: His enlightenment is so big that in his
Speaker 1: presence the whole world would disappear.
Speaker 1: One felt that one was suddenly sitting at
Speaker 1: the heart of the cosmos.
Speaker 1: The spiritual energy that was vibrating in
Speaker 1: and around his physical form and through
Speaker 1: his persona was absolutely overwhelming.
Speaker 1: I haven't before and since I've never met
Speaker 1: such a being who was so powerfully awake
Speaker 1: that could transmit this state to other
Speaker 1: people so effortlessly, in such a way that
Speaker 1: a lot of people never recovered from
Speaker 1: meeting him.
Speaker 1: But that didn't mean he was egoless.
Speaker 1: He seemed to be egoless when he was in
Speaker 1: these dramatic higher states, but the rest
Speaker 1: of the time his ego was in good shape, very
Speaker 1: present and active, and sometimes not so
Speaker 1: pretty.
Speaker 1: Did that mean he wasn't enlightened?
Speaker 1: Absolutely not.
Speaker 1: It did that mean he wasn't enlightened?
Speaker 1: It did not mean he wasn't enlightened.
Speaker 1: This is the whole paradox I'm trying to
Speaker 1: bring to all of you.
Speaker 1: It didn't mean he wasn't enlightened.
Speaker 1: It meant he had issues, like so many of us
Speaker 1: do.
Speaker 1: He had big issues.
Speaker 1: He was a very powerful man, for better and
Speaker 1: for worse.
Speaker 1: He was a very powerful man for better and
Speaker 1: But his awakening to enlightened awareness
Speaker 1: was undoubtable.
Speaker 1: It was impossible to doubt or impossible to
Speaker 1: question, because when he was vibrating it
Speaker 1: was like sitting in front of God.
Speaker 1: Time and space seemed to warp around him.
Speaker 1: And they did.
Speaker 1: And the day I met him, which is March 25th
Speaker 1: 1986, is the day my life changed forever
Speaker 1: simply because I met him and experienced
Speaker 1: his grace and sat in front of him and as a
Speaker 1: result of that meeting, I had an experience
Speaker 1: of awakening after about 10 minutes.
Speaker 1: So I asked him during my early weeks with
Speaker 1: him.
Speaker 1: I said with enlightenment?
Speaker 1: I said does the ego die?
Speaker 1: And he said no, the ego doesn't die, but it
Speaker 1: becomes sattvic.
Speaker 1: Sattvic means peaceful, he said so the
Speaker 1: effect of enlightened awareness is that the
Speaker 1: ego becomes pacified.
Speaker 1: So it doesn't die, but it becomes pacified.
Speaker 1: So so, so one of the points I wanted to
Speaker 1: make in this talk was that in the
Speaker 1: therapeutic context, we want to understand
Speaker 1: why we're suffering.
Speaker 1: We want to come to an understanding of why
Speaker 1: we're suffering.
Speaker 1: What are the issues or the events that
Speaker 1: happened in our past that created very
Speaker 1: negative impressions in our nervous systems
Speaker 1: and in our souls?
Speaker 1: As long as they remain unresolved, they're
Speaker 1: going to continue to cause us trouble and
Speaker 1: cause us to suffer.
Speaker 1: In the present moment.
Speaker 1: With the awakening to enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: what happens is that the awakening to
Speaker 1: higher consciousness reveals what's
Speaker 1: instantly recognized to be a much deeper
Speaker 1: dimension of reality.
Speaker 1: What experiences?
Speaker 1: It seems like a deeper truth, not only
Speaker 1: about oneself and one's history, but about
Speaker 1: life itself, about existence and the
Speaker 1: discovery of this deeper truth about
Speaker 1: reality, about life and existence, is so
Speaker 1: unthinkably positive, so unthinkably
Speaker 1: positive that it, at least temporarily,
Speaker 1: displaces our obsession with our own
Speaker 1: suffering, obsession with our own misery,
Speaker 1: and obsession with our own misery and our
Speaker 1: obsession with our own pain, and so and so,
Speaker 1: once this happens, we want to see well,
Speaker 1: what can I do to, what do I need to do to
Speaker 1: remain conscious of this deeper truth that
Speaker 1: becomes what spiritual practice is all
Speaker 1: about?
Speaker 1: What is it that we need to do?
Speaker 1: What is it that I need to do?
Speaker 1: What is it that I need to do in order to
Speaker 1: remain conscious of this deeper truth?
Speaker 1: Because if I'm conscious of this deeper
Speaker 1: truth, my obsession with my own egos, pain
Speaker 1: and suffering and misery and grief will be
Speaker 1: displaced.
Speaker 1: Grief will be displaced and usually the
Speaker 1: intensity of that state of consciousness
Speaker 1: will continue to displace our experience of
Speaker 1: pain and suffering and misery and grief.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, some people say, a lot of
Speaker 1: people say, especially psychotherapists say
Speaker 1: that those individuals who are obsessed
Speaker 1: with higher states of consciousness are
Speaker 1: using their experiences of these higher
Speaker 1: states to spiritually bypass or to avoid
Speaker 1: their own shadows, their own unresolved
Speaker 1: issues.
Speaker 1: And if that's true, if that's true, if
Speaker 1: that's true and often it is true that would
Speaker 1: mean that our spiritual part, part of a
Speaker 1: fundamental part of our spiritual practice,
Speaker 1: would have to be facing the difficult
Speaker 1: truths about ourselves that we tend to like
Speaker 1: to avoid.
Speaker 1: And just in case anybody's wondering about
Speaker 1: my approach to all this, in my own teaching
Speaker 1: work of evolutionary enlightenment I have
Speaker 1: five fundamental principles that I work
Speaker 1: with, and the first is cultivating the
Speaker 1: unconditional desire for liberation, first
Speaker 1: and foremost, as a first principle, one's
Speaker 1: relationship to existence, into life itself.
Speaker 1: I wanna be free more than anything else.
Speaker 1: First and foremost, more than I wanna be
Speaker 1: rich, more than I wanna be famous, more
Speaker 1: than I wanna be anything, I wanna be free.
Speaker 1: I wanna know what the Buddha knew.
Speaker 1: But the second says if you want to be free,
Speaker 1: if you truly want to be free, you have to
Speaker 1: learn to take responsibility from all of
Speaker 1: your karma, all of your karma past, present
Speaker 1: and even future.
Speaker 1: Because if you're aspiring anybody who's
Speaker 1: aspiring to become a bodhisattva also have
Speaker 1: to take responsibility for what has yet to
Speaker 1: happen for the future.
Speaker 1: So the second principle of the teaching
Speaker 1: tells us if we want to be free, we have to
Speaker 1: be willing to take on conditional, absolute
Speaker 1: and radical responsibility for our karma
Speaker 1: coming from our past, present and also the
Speaker 1: future.
Speaker 1: And the third principle that I teach is if
Speaker 1: we want to take responsibility for karma
Speaker 1: past, present and future how are we going
Speaker 1: to do it?
Speaker 1: The only way to do it is going to be by
Speaker 1: facing everything and avoiding nothing, and
Speaker 1: that is not an easy form of spiritual
Speaker 1: practice to do.
Speaker 1: It says if you want to be free, more than
Speaker 1: anything else, you have to face everything
Speaker 1: and avoid nothing.
Speaker 1: We have to learn how to face everything and
Speaker 1: avoid nothing, and speaking about it is one
Speaker 1: thing, doing it is another.
Speaker 1: It's very difficult because the ego, your
Speaker 1: ego, my ego, the ego tends to have a great
Speaker 1: resistance and reluctance to face
Speaker 1: everything and avoid nothing, especially
Speaker 1: issues about ourselves that make us feel
Speaker 1: uncomfortable or ill at ease, that don't
Speaker 1: make us feel so good about ourselves.
Speaker 1: So facing everything and avoiding nothing
Speaker 1: requires a lot of humility and a depth of
Speaker 1: resolve for purification at the level of
Speaker 1: the soul.
Speaker 1: It's not for the faint of heart.
Speaker 1: So one thing to understand that the in
Speaker 1: terms of the, in terms of this distinction
Speaker 1: I'm making in this talk between the
Speaker 1: enlightenment perspective and the
Speaker 1: therapeutic perspective, is that when we're
Speaker 1: trying to heal the ego when we're trying to
Speaker 1: heal it in a psychological context.
Speaker 1: If you work with a good therapist, you
Speaker 1: won't demonize it.
Speaker 1: You won't demonize the ego.
Speaker 1: That'll just make the division or the split
Speaker 1: in the self even deeper, because of course
Speaker 1: the goal in the therapeutic context is for
Speaker 1: the wounded self that's become divided
Speaker 1: against itself to become healed and become
Speaker 1: whole, to reunify with itself in the
Speaker 1: attempt to resolve the trauma, resolve the
Speaker 1: split.
Speaker 1: But I'm losing track on my direction here.
Speaker 1: Just give me a second.
Speaker 1: Yes, but what happens?
Speaker 1: What I wanted to say is that the this is
Speaker 1: something that not a lot of people know
Speaker 1: about is that, from the perspective of
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, when you awaken to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness within yourself, when
Speaker 1: you awaken to enlightened awareness within
Speaker 1: yourself, when you start seeing, perceiving
Speaker 1: reality through a different lens lens of
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness itself you start to
Speaker 1: find the presence of the ego or separate
Speaker 1: self-sense, especially in individuals that
Speaker 1: are particularly and uniquely identified
Speaker 1: with their separate self-sense and
Speaker 1: individuals who have particularly
Speaker 1: narcissistic tendencies.
Speaker 1: From the perspective of the awakening to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, seen through the
Speaker 1: lens of enlightened awareness, the ego is
Speaker 1: seen as an obstruction.
Speaker 1: I remember when I was I'm 67 now, so I
Speaker 1: started experimenting with psychedelic
Speaker 1: drugs when I was far too young, when I was
Speaker 1: about 16.
Speaker 1: I took a very powerful dose of LSD and I
Speaker 1: remember a friend of mine had a very big
Speaker 1: ego.
Speaker 1: He was quite a narcissistic character and
Speaker 1: me and a bunch of my friends were in the
Speaker 1: country and we took a particularly large
Speaker 1: dose of this powerful psychedelic drug.
Speaker 1: And I remember when my friend walked in I'm
Speaker 1: sure many of you have had this kind of
Speaker 1: experience His ego was.
Speaker 1: It was so ugly and I suddenly saw, I saw it.
Speaker 1: I saw it through the lens of this kind of
Speaker 1: psychedelic state.
Speaker 1: I saw his ego as this monstrosity, as this
Speaker 1: ugly creature or appendage.
Speaker 1: It was particularly shocking and
Speaker 1: particularly painful.
Speaker 1: Of course this was the effect of the
Speaker 1: psychedelic substance.
Speaker 1: Of course animated this particular
Speaker 1: reactivity.
Speaker 1: But when we awaken to enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: the ego is felt to be an obstacle, it's
Speaker 1: suddenly seen as not our friend.
Speaker 1: So it's not because the, because the
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness has its own
Speaker 1: self-sense.
Speaker 1: When you awaken to enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: you awaken to a different part of your own
Speaker 1: self, and a different part of your own self
Speaker 1: has particular sensibilities, preferences,
Speaker 1: likes and dislikes.
Speaker 1: And so when you awaken to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, in similar ways as to how
Speaker 1: reality can seem from the perspective of
Speaker 1: being in a trance state activated by
Speaker 1: psychedelic substances, you can become more
Speaker 1: sensitive to particular issues that
Speaker 1: ordinarily would not be bothersome.
Speaker 1: So I just wanted to make this point that
Speaker 1: while in a therapeutic context we want to
Speaker 1: befriend the ego and don't want to alienate
Speaker 1: it, so we can help to serve its
Speaker 1: reunification with itself, heal the wounds,
Speaker 1: when we see the ego from a deeply awakened
Speaker 1: state of enlightened awareness, we see the
Speaker 1: problem that it is because it wants to
Speaker 1: remain separate.
Speaker 1: It stands against cosmic unity.
Speaker 1: Unknowingly, it can't help.
Speaker 1: It.
Speaker 1: It's not deliberate.
Speaker 1: It's not deliberate or intentional, it's
Speaker 1: just that its entire position in
Speaker 1: relationship to existence and to life
Speaker 1: itself is to stand apart and to be separate.
Speaker 1: It doesn't want to die, drown in love, it
Speaker 1: does not want to disappear into our
Speaker 1: absolute or cosmic unity.
Speaker 1: So when we awaken to enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: we discover that the ego can be very
Speaker 1: problematic for us, especially if we also
Speaker 1: are very interested in enlightenment.
Speaker 1: Ironically, the more interested in
Speaker 1: enlightenment you are, the more serious you
Speaker 1: are about it, the more problematic the ego
Speaker 1: can become.
Speaker 1: Because even though the ego doesn't die at
Speaker 1: least in my experience and most of the
Speaker 1: others I've observed the ego has to somehow,
Speaker 1: in some mysterious way has to be
Speaker 1: experientially convinced, or you, whoever
Speaker 1: you are, have to be experientially
Speaker 1: convinced about that which is higher and
Speaker 1: more real, in such a way that your ego will
Speaker 1: willingly step aside and become second
Speaker 1: fiddle.
Speaker 1: The ego always wants to be the star of its
Speaker 1: own movie.
Speaker 1: Like I've been saying for many years, our
Speaker 1: narcissism, which is arrogant
Speaker 1: self-importance, undeserved, unearned,
Speaker 1: arrogant self-importance.
Speaker 1: For our postmodern, conditioned narcissism,
Speaker 1: which is the unearned superiority it means.
Speaker 1: I want to be able to stand out and be seen
Speaker 1: as being separate from the other, the
Speaker 1: others, the world and the whole universe.
Speaker 1: It's a desire to stand out and away from
Speaker 1: the whole, or the others or the world.
Speaker 1: I want you to see me.
Speaker 1: I don't want to disappear, I don't want to
Speaker 1: die into the infinite, that which is
Speaker 1: eternal.
Speaker 1: I want you to see me.
Speaker 1: And the ego doesn't want to let go of its
Speaker 1: own uniqueness, its own specialness, its
Speaker 1: own separateness.
Speaker 1: And it's a contrary position to the very
Speaker 1: inner momentum of enlightened awareness
Speaker 1: itself, because enlightened awareness is
Speaker 1: the feeling or the sense, the momentum of
Speaker 1: unity, which is the ultimate nature of
Speaker 1: reality, the ultimate nature of the cosmos.
Speaker 1: The ultimate truth about the cosmos is the
Speaker 1: principle truth that Vedanta speaks so
Speaker 1: loudly about.
Speaker 1: Vedanta tells us that the ultimate truth
Speaker 1: about the nature of reality is that there's
Speaker 1: only one and not two.
Speaker 1: And I am, and you all are that one without
Speaker 1: a second.
Speaker 1: I am that, and the ego says no, I'm not, no,
Speaker 1: I'm not and no, I won't.
Speaker 1: So then, of course, if, if this is the
Speaker 1: situation, then of course you need a
Speaker 1: spiritual teacher, a spiritual master,
Speaker 1: someone who's actually crossed this rubric
Speaker 1: on, who could help you to deal with these
Speaker 1: conflicting motives in your own self, the
Speaker 1: part of you that wants to be
Speaker 1: unconditionally free and liberated, wants
Speaker 1: to die in love and cosmic unity once and
Speaker 1: for all and forever, eternally, for
Speaker 1: eternity, never to return again.
Speaker 1: And your ego's refusal to let go to
Speaker 1: relinquish its own power.
Speaker 1: And the ego's refusal to let go to
Speaker 1: So for the enlightenment, for the awakening
Speaker 1: to enlighten awareness to become stable.
Speaker 1: In other words, a lot of people find it
Speaker 1: easy, given the right circumstances, to
Speaker 1: awaken briefly and temporarily, but usually
Speaker 1: the awakening to enlightened awareness is a
Speaker 1: brief flight from the torment and the
Speaker 1: tyranny of the ego story.
Speaker 1: Most people fall back again very quickly
Speaker 1: into the ego's world, wondering where did
Speaker 1: it all go?
Speaker 1: So for the enlightenment to be able to
Speaker 1: stick for one's spiritual self-confidence.
Speaker 1: To be able to stick for the spiritual
Speaker 1: self-confidence, to be able to become
Speaker 1: strong, the ego has to be.
Speaker 1: It's very simple really, but it's very
Speaker 1: difficult.
Speaker 1: The ego has to be willing to become second
Speaker 1: fiddle, not first fiddle, not star of the
Speaker 1: movie anymore.
Speaker 1: You can be here if you want, but you've got
Speaker 1: to become number two, second, best, second,
Speaker 1: important.
Speaker 1: Your importance is no longer primary, it
Speaker 1: needs to become secondary and ego.
Speaker 1: Most people, most people at the level of
Speaker 1: ego, would rather die and give up being the
Speaker 1: most special one in the whole universe,
Speaker 1: because the ego thrives on being special.
Speaker 1: Can you see how special I am?
Speaker 1: I'm either special because I'm more
Speaker 1: talented, more intelligent, more beautiful,
Speaker 1: because I'm more traumatized, more screwed
Speaker 1: up and I suffer more than you.
Speaker 1: The ego doesn't really care how it can be
Speaker 1: seen as special.
Speaker 1: It'll do anything to hold onto the position
Speaker 1: of being seen as special, even if it means
Speaker 1: it's a result of pain and suffering.
Speaker 1: It's ironic and tragic.
Speaker 1: So the big challenge is you, whoever you
Speaker 1: are and this is true for all of us, if we
Speaker 1: want to be able to awaken to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness in such a way that it will become
Speaker 1: relatively stable is that we have to be
Speaker 1: willing to die.
Speaker 1: Our ego has to be willing to relinquish its
Speaker 1: irrational need to be number one within the
Speaker 1: story of your own life.
Speaker 1: So if there's anything, if ego death is
Speaker 1: real, then I can see this in people when
Speaker 1: they you can tell if you meet a true seeker
Speaker 1: or someone who's a true finder.
Speaker 1: In most true finders there's a softness in
Speaker 1: their persona and their personality.
Speaker 1: The way the personality expresses itself is
Speaker 1: a softness and a kindness that reflects
Speaker 1: that they've let go significantly at the
Speaker 1: deepest level of their being.
Speaker 1: A big letting go has happened.
Speaker 1: It doesn't mean it's an unconditioned,
Speaker 1: absolute letting go of the ego.
Speaker 1: It doesn't mean they're fully enlightened
Speaker 1: for eternity, whatever that means, but it
Speaker 1: means their soul.
Speaker 1: It means they've allowed their soul to
Speaker 1: become wounded by the love of God, so to
Speaker 1: speak, the love of the infinite, the love
Speaker 1: of the absolute.
Speaker 1: They've allowed that which is primary and
Speaker 1: absolute to take the first place and that
Speaker 1: they have humbled themselves before God in
Speaker 1: an essential, a fundamental, irreducible
Speaker 1: way.
Speaker 1: And this doesn't mean that the ego is gone
Speaker 1: forever, it doesn't mean it's left the room,
Speaker 1: but it means that you can feel the humility
Speaker 1: in the true seeker.
Speaker 1: This is a certain kind of arrogance that
Speaker 1: they have seen to have transcended, at
Speaker 1: least in a significant way, and that's
Speaker 1: because there's been a deep measure of
Speaker 1: surrender through this higher principle.
Speaker 1: And of course, once that surrender has
Speaker 1: happened, once it's taken place, once a
Speaker 1: decision has been made, once that letting
Speaker 1: go has happened, doesn't mean one has
Speaker 1: reached the yonder shore and never to
Speaker 1: return again or anything like that, but it
Speaker 1: means now one's spiritual practice is
Speaker 1: working on letting go more and more and
Speaker 1: more and more and more, but at least one
Speaker 1: now is living in the momentum of
Speaker 1: transcendence.
Speaker 1: And it means that one's pride and arrogance
Speaker 1: has been punctured, not ultimately defeated,
Speaker 1: but punctured.
Speaker 1: It means it's been wounded in a good way,
Speaker 1: spiritually wounded, in a very positive way,
Speaker 1: and to do the kind of work that I'm doing,
Speaker 1: that, that that wounding or that puncturing
Speaker 1: of the small self and it's and it's willing
Speaker 1: to, and the willingness in that context to
Speaker 1: take second to the ego, to take second
Speaker 1: place, willingly, happily, joyously, is
Speaker 1: essential for spiritual work even to be
Speaker 1: able to begin to spiritual work, to be able
Speaker 1: to begin in earnest, because until that's
Speaker 1: happened, all the spiritual work to be able
Speaker 1: happened, all the spiritual work is just
Speaker 1: happening on the level of the intellect or
Speaker 1: the level of kind of performance.
Speaker 1: You know, spiritual practice only happens
Speaker 1: once the ego has been punctured in a
Speaker 1: serious way and one has stopped resisting
Speaker 1: the love of God.
Speaker 1: Often I think about this question, about
Speaker 1: ego death.
Speaker 1: What does it mean?
Speaker 1: What does it look like?
Speaker 1: I often think about my own guru who was, as
Speaker 1: I described him, very powerfully awake,
Speaker 1: powerfully enlightened.
Speaker 1: He also had a very strong sense of an ego,
Speaker 1: a very strong self-sense.
Speaker 1: He was a powerful man and the only way I
Speaker 1: can metaphorically describe to you what
Speaker 1: that looks like is that, if you imagine,
Speaker 1: imagine the ego as this big shield for lack
Speaker 1: of a better word this frontal shield, and
Speaker 1: imagine, imagine if, as a result of a
Speaker 1: powerful awakening, a huge hole had been
Speaker 1: made in the shield and through this hole,
Speaker 1: the light of the love of God, the love of
Speaker 1: the absolute, the immensity and the
Speaker 1: inconceivable glory and goodness of higher
Speaker 1: consciousness, the transcendental radiance,
Speaker 1: will be shining through that huge hole.
Speaker 1: The shield is still there, which is a
Speaker 1: metaphor for the frontal self of the ego,
Speaker 1: ego personality, but it's been punctured,
Speaker 1: it's been wounded, and in people whose
Speaker 1: awakening is profound and enormous and
Speaker 1: powerful and transformative.
Speaker 1: It means that there's a huge hole in their
Speaker 1: psyche, and transformative means that
Speaker 1: there's a huge hole in their psyche and
Speaker 1: through that hole, the light of God, the
Speaker 1: light of the absolute, the light of
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, shines through.
Speaker 1: So the light and the radiance of God,
Speaker 1: consciousness, shines through their egos.
Speaker 1: There's a couple of other things I wanted
Speaker 1: to say.
Speaker 1: I wanted to add to this picture is that
Speaker 1: there's many different ways to describe the
Speaker 1: ego and many different spiritual teachers
Speaker 1: and spiritual gurus and psychotherapists
Speaker 1: and innovators of all kinds have their own
Speaker 1: theories about what these self-structures
Speaker 1: look like and how they work.
Speaker 1: So I have a very simple model, which is
Speaker 1: just a simple model.
Speaker 1: The map is not the territory.
Speaker 1: So I want to make clear the map is not the
Speaker 1: territory.
Speaker 1: So what I'm saying, what I'm about to
Speaker 1: describe to you about the ego, is just one
Speaker 1: helpful way to think about it, but it's not
Speaker 1: absolutely real.
Speaker 1: Just to, you can use it as a tool to help
Speaker 1: you understand something that's very
Speaker 1: difficult to understand.
Speaker 1: But the ego is, uh, the organizing
Speaker 1: principle in the psyche.
Speaker 1: So we want the organizing principle in the
Speaker 1: psyche to be in good shape, because if the
Speaker 1: organizing principle in the psyche is in
Speaker 1: bad shape, you are going to be a mess.
Speaker 1: It means yourself will be broken in many
Speaker 1: different pieces and this is not a state or
Speaker 1: position or a state of consciousness or
Speaker 1: relationship to reality that any of us want
Speaker 1: to be subject to.
Speaker 1: That's a state of madness.
Speaker 1: So the ego is a self-organizing principle
Speaker 1: in the psyche.
Speaker 1: We want the ego to be in good shape.
Speaker 1: We want the ego to be healthy and strong.
Speaker 1: So what I call positive ego is when we have
Speaker 1: a positive relationship to our unique
Speaker 1: self-identity, when we believe that we are
Speaker 1: a good person At the level of the soul.
Speaker 1: We believe that we are inherently good
Speaker 1: person, the level of the soul.
Speaker 1: We believe that we are inherently good,
Speaker 1: which means we are lovable, we're worth
Speaker 1: loving, we are worthy of love, worthy of
Speaker 1: respect, worthy of the kindness and
Speaker 1: generosity of others.
Speaker 1: We believe in our own inherent decency and
Speaker 1: goodness and we also believe in our own
Speaker 1: worthiness Very important also believe in
Speaker 1: our own worthiness very important.
Speaker 1: We believe in our own worthiness, which
Speaker 1: means we have a measure of self-confidence
Speaker 1: because we believe in ourselves at the
Speaker 1: level of self.
Speaker 1: It's a positive ego and a lot of
Speaker 1: psychological work and also a lot of
Speaker 1: spiritual work, to be honest, is really
Speaker 1: about cultivating a positive ego.
Speaker 1: Sometimes we have to do a lot of
Speaker 1: psychological work and also a lot of
Speaker 1: spiritual work to get to the point where we
Speaker 1: can honestly say we respect ourselves, that
Speaker 1: where we love ourselves, small self, love
Speaker 1: ourselves, respect ourselves and believe in
Speaker 1: our own worthiness.
Speaker 1: So the negative ego is a place of our
Speaker 1: woundedness, a place of unresolved trauma,
Speaker 1: of fear and anger, resentment, rage and so
Speaker 1: much pain.
Speaker 1: Now, if we create bad karma and everybody
Speaker 1: does to some degree or other it's usually
Speaker 1: because of the ways we have been wounded
Speaker 1: and traumatized and suffered is the result
Speaker 1: of our woundedness, is usually the cause of
Speaker 1: all of our self-destructive behavior.
Speaker 1: And, as I was just saying, a lot of
Speaker 1: psychological work and a lot of spiritual,
Speaker 1: a lot of psychological work and a lot of
Speaker 1: spiritual work.
Speaker 1: In the end, it's about healing these wounds
Speaker 1: so that we can become self-respecting,
Speaker 1: powerfully kind, spiritually inspired,
Speaker 1: trustworthy it's an important one
Speaker 1: trustworthy, trustworthy, deeply
Speaker 1: trustworthy, very deeply trustworthy
Speaker 1: friends to ourselves and to other people.
Speaker 1: Too many of us aren't really trustworthy in
Speaker 1: the end.
Speaker 1: People who aren't trustworthy will always
Speaker 1: end up betraying themselves and betraying
Speaker 1: you.
Speaker 1: That's a result, and they do that because
Speaker 1: they can't seem to help themselves not do
Speaker 1: it.
Speaker 1: That's the negative ego.
Speaker 1: The negative ego needs work, and all of us.
Speaker 1: It needs work.
Speaker 1: It needs whatever work, it needs to heal.
Speaker 1: Now, as I said earlier in the call, in the
Speaker 1: psychological context, healing usually
Speaker 1: comes as a result of coming to an
Speaker 1: understanding and experiential and
Speaker 1: emotional experiential and also
Speaker 1: intellectual understanding of what happened,
Speaker 1: happened, what the causes were to the
Speaker 1: problem.
Speaker 1: But the spiritual healing, as far as I
Speaker 1: understand it and I experience it, is very
Speaker 1: different, as I already explained, is
Speaker 1: because we've discovered something that is
Speaker 1: higher and deeper and more real and more
Speaker 1: substantial than any psychological
Speaker 1: experience, positive and negative could
Speaker 1: ever be.
Speaker 1: And in that context, it is our direct
Speaker 1: cognizance of that which is higher and more
Speaker 1: deeply real that freezes more and more from
Speaker 1: the, from the negative tendencies and
Speaker 1: negative conditioning that come from the
Speaker 1: negative ego.
Speaker 1: And the way I approach this, it's my belief,
Speaker 1: it's my conviction, it's part of my
Speaker 1: philosophy, my teaching philosophy is that
Speaker 1: I believe that the more we wake up, the
Speaker 1: more sincerely we wake up, wake up, the
Speaker 1: more we have the courage to be authentic
Speaker 1: and transparent.
Speaker 1: And the more we have the courage to be
Speaker 1: authentic and transparent and the more
Speaker 1: inspired by the higher states of
Speaker 1: consciousness, by the God consciousness, to
Speaker 1: keep our dignity, because God consciousness,
Speaker 1: or higher consciousness, or transcendental
Speaker 1: awareness and awakening to non-duality, if
Speaker 1: it's the real thing, will compel us to be
Speaker 1: dignified and if it's the real thing, will
Speaker 1: compel us to be dignified to do the right
Speaker 1: thing.
Speaker 1: Because inherent in the spiritual awakening
Speaker 1: is the discovery of, and the presence of a
Speaker 1: moral imperative which would compel us, if
Speaker 1: you have the heart to hear it, to do a
Speaker 1: little better, to make a little bit more
Speaker 1: effort, to care a little bit more, not to
Speaker 1: fall apart, but to be a little bit more
Speaker 1: anti-fragile, a little bit more strong, so
Speaker 1: we can fight the good fight.
Speaker 1: I believe that's what we're all here for.
Speaker 1: After all, we've got to be here for a
Speaker 1: reason.
Speaker 1: I don't think life is a random accident and
Speaker 1: I don't think I'm a random accident and I
Speaker 1: don't think you're a random accident.
Speaker 1: I think we're all here for a very good
Speaker 1: reason.
Speaker 1: But if we're here for a good reason and
Speaker 1: from the perspective of God consciousness,
Speaker 1: that reason seems to be a reflection of the
Speaker 1: energy and intelligence that created the
Speaker 1: universe in and through the body, mind,
Speaker 1: personality that God gave you gave all of
Speaker 1: us.
Speaker 1: So I think we all, when we awaken deeply
Speaker 1: enough, we'll feel an obligation to become
Speaker 1: a reflection of our own highest potential,
Speaker 1: not just for our own sake but for everyone
Speaker 1: else's sake, because when you awaken deeply
Speaker 1: enough, you keep on realizing there's a
Speaker 1: larger purpose to this whole process that
Speaker 1: we're in the midst of.
Speaker 1: The human experience is not just an ego
Speaker 1: trip Many people seem to think from their
Speaker 1: behavior, seem to think that it is.
Speaker 1: The human experience is not, ladies and
Speaker 1: gentlemen, just an ego trip.
Speaker 1: It's a cosmic event that's unfolding
Speaker 1: throughout through us.
Speaker 1: It's full of challenges, full of paradoxes
Speaker 1: and difficult paradoxes and difficult
Speaker 1: contradictions, and full of pain and
Speaker 1: suffering.
Speaker 1: But if you awaken deeply enough, you see
Speaker 1: there's a higher principle at work that
Speaker 1: makes it all worth it, no matter how tough
Speaker 1: it is, no matter how tough it seems to be.
Speaker 1: So one of the ways that I think about ego
Speaker 1: death is that is that we become so moved by
Speaker 1: these transcendental truths as a result of
Speaker 1: being a deep experience with the personal
Speaker 1: world, of the separate self-sense,
Speaker 1: including all of the ways it's been
Speaker 1: culturally conditioned by unenlightened
Speaker 1: parents and teachers, has been
Speaker 1: fundamentally dislodged from the source of
Speaker 1: our self-sense.
Speaker 1: In other words.
Speaker 1: There is this now, close to the source of
Speaker 1: our self-sense.
Speaker 1: There is a vast open space of infinite
Speaker 1: freedom and unimaginable potential that's
Speaker 1: always available, and it's who and what God
Speaker 1: actually is.
Speaker 1: Not what our ego tells us, not what other
Speaker 1: peoples have told us, not all the terrible
Speaker 1: things that happen to be true about human
Speaker 1: life.
Speaker 1: We discover there's a deeper truth that
Speaker 1: transcends anything that happens in time
Speaker 1: and space, and the more we have surrendered
Speaker 1: to this deeper dimension space, and the
Speaker 1: more we have surrendered to this deeper
Speaker 1: dimension of reality, the more that
Speaker 1: mysterious space will be present within us
Speaker 1: that will always ensure our freedom and our
Speaker 1: liberation, in spite of maybe being given a
Speaker 1: very difficult deck of cards, in spite of
Speaker 1: the enormous challenges we're all gonna
Speaker 1: face on a human level.
Speaker 1: There's something else that's become first
Speaker 1: and foremost in our attention, in our
Speaker 1: awareness, in our experience.
Speaker 1: So we wanna see death of the ego more, as
Speaker 1: when you meet people and you get to know
Speaker 1: them, especially if you get to know them,
Speaker 1: especially if you get to know them are they
Speaker 1: living for use mythic language.
Speaker 1: For some reason, I'm falling into that
Speaker 1: habit.
Speaker 1: I'm not sure why I'm doing it, but the
Speaker 1: thing is, when you get to know people.
Speaker 1: Is this person living first and foremost
Speaker 1: for God or the absolute, the ultimate
Speaker 1: mystery that lies between life and death?
Speaker 1: Is that what they're living for and is that
Speaker 1: what they're living from?
Speaker 1: Are they trapped in the story of the small
Speaker 1: self, trapped in our collective story, or
Speaker 1: is some part of their persona and heart,
Speaker 1: small self, trapped in our collective story,
Speaker 1: or some part of their persona and heart
Speaker 1: fundamentally liberated and vibrating with
Speaker 1: a deeper conviction about what's true?
Speaker 1: So the death of the ego or the reduction of
Speaker 1: its influence on our being can be seen if
Speaker 1: you, if it depends on you, you know you can
Speaker 1: only, you can only see and understand as
Speaker 1: much, as much as you can have experienced
Speaker 1: yourself.
Speaker 1: But if your soul has been, if a soul, sorry,
Speaker 1: if a hole has been punctured in your soul
Speaker 1: and that hole is to God of the absolute,
Speaker 1: you're going to know and it's all.
Speaker 1: Everyone else Doesn't mean your ego's gone,
Speaker 1: doesn't mean it's not going to continue to
Speaker 1: make great problems for you either, and
Speaker 1: other people also.
Speaker 1: The ego doesn't let go very easily, as we
Speaker 1: all know.
Speaker 1: I used to call the ego the irrational
Speaker 1: refusal, the irrational refusenik.
Speaker 1: It's the part of us that says no, I won't.
Speaker 1: Irrational refusal, the irrational
Speaker 1: refusenik, it's the part of us that says no,
Speaker 1: I won't, even though we know we should.
Speaker 1: We know we should, but we say I won't.
Speaker 1: You say, well, what's the matter?
Speaker 1: Why not?
Speaker 1: You say because I don't want to.
Speaker 1: Why?
Speaker 1: Because I don't.
Speaker 1: So the ego, from the perspective of
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, can be seen as the
Speaker 1: irrational refusenik or the irrational no.
Speaker 1: And so it's getting you, getting me or you,
Speaker 1: whoever you are, whoever I am, to say yes
Speaker 1: in spite of that and that's a very
Speaker 1: difficult thing to do In spite of the no of
Speaker 1: the ego remaining in the unconditional yes,
Speaker 1: and that's what I call ego death.
Speaker 1: And everything that I'm describing to you
Speaker 1: can be done.
Speaker 1: It's not, um, it's not out of it's not out
Speaker 1: of most people's reach, even though most
Speaker 1: people don't do it, because it's just more
Speaker 1: than most people want.
Speaker 1: Most people don't want to go that deep.
Speaker 1: Very good, I have more to say on this
Speaker 1: mysterious subject, but I think I'll leave
Speaker 1: it at that for now.
Speaker 1: I just want to end saying that
Speaker 1: enlightenment is real, that it exists, that
Speaker 1: it's attainable please don't doubt it
Speaker 1: exists, that it's attainable, please don't
Speaker 1: doubt it and also that the most important
Speaker 1: thing, if you're sincere and serious about
Speaker 1: this is not that the ego is eradicated
Speaker 1: completely, totally and unconditionally,
Speaker 1: because that's probably not going to happen
Speaker 1: and, most importantly, it doesn't need to
Speaker 1: happen but the ego has to bow down and has
Speaker 1: to be willing to become the second fiddle
Speaker 1: in the story of your life, not my life,
Speaker 1: your life.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there was one more thing I wanted to
Speaker 1: mention, which I will, which is for our
Speaker 1: pride.
Speaker 1: This is just positive pride and negative
Speaker 1: Positive pride is self respect.
Speaker 1: It's all good, but the negative pride is
Speaker 1: the part of your ego, the ego, our ego,
Speaker 1: that would rather die than bow down.
Speaker 1: That's the biggest obstacle to the
Speaker 1: awakening to enlightened awareness that
Speaker 1: would rather die than bow down.
Speaker 1: That's the biggest obstacle to the
Speaker 1: awakening to enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: Is the vicious pride that we feel as this
Speaker 1: ferocious reluctance to bow down, to give
Speaker 1: in, to say, not my will, but thy will be
Speaker 1: done.
Speaker 1: So it's the irrational refusal to bow down,
Speaker 1: become second fiddle.
Speaker 1: It's the most difficult expression of ego.
Speaker 1: For those who are most serious about this,
Speaker 1: it's pride.
Speaker 1: So be aware of pride, be very aware of
Speaker 1: pride, be very aware of your pride.
Speaker 1: Positive pride is good, it's self-respect.
Speaker 1: The pride of the ego, the arrogant pride,
Speaker 1: is very dangerous and can be a big problem
Speaker 1: for those who want to be free, but nothing
Speaker 1: that I have spoken about so far is
Speaker 1: unattainable.
Speaker 1: It's all within your grasp if you want it.
Speaker 1: Badly enough you.